the chief white house correspondent for
the associated press during the obama
administration ben feller wrote
extensively about the president about
other world leaders and about the most
important issues of the day now he's
writing about another very important
topic that would be parenting feller's
first children's book big problem little
problem or big problems little problems
is a heartwarming story that teaches
kids and adults how to take on life's
daily challenges it's inspired by his
own 10 year old son sam and ben joins us
now
so you tell the story of how the idea
for this book came together in the book
itself but if you could help us out it's
the zipper problem
absolutely well look this is a story
about how to make life a little bit
easier for our kids and for ourselves as
parents because who couldn't use that
and and really begins with the boy who's
overwhelmed by a problem that he thinks
is just too much how do i zip the zipper
because all kids have these in their
daily lives i can't find my cape i can't
zip her up my coat and it does seem
overwhelming
and so the dad tries to make it smaller
for him by slowing down the moment
solving the problem and celebrating the
win and as the story goes on the boy
really learns patience and perspective
the point where he can teach that
background was this a piece of fatherly
wisdom that someone had given to you
that you're passing on or just a
spontaneous in the moment parenting
insight i think it's really a
culmination of my whole life as a as a
reporter and as an advisor is how do you
solve problems how do you solve problems
you make it smaller you distill the
story down to what's simpler and that
just came naturally to me
and helping my son and really when i saw
him start to get empowered and feel like
i can own this day a little bit better
that's when i felt like i really might
have something here to share i actually
think it could help many adults too
because when you look at uh when you
look at something that seems
overwhelming to just take a minute you
even talk about breathing ask yourself
is it a big problem is it a little
problem and in most cases it really is a
little problem if you think about it
don't you think yeah i mean you got to
have that perspective the thing is the
kids they don't have it yet why would
they as grown-ups if we miss the train
or we spill our coffee we can't find our
keys we know how to live through that
moment as frustrating as it is because
it's happened hundreds of times yeah but
if it's the first time for a kid they
don't know the difference between a big
problem or a little problem so it's up
to us as parents to show them that and
give them that perspective every book
comes with uh a critic right
everybody has a critic here we go
including you ben and yeah we have one
of those critics um a little messy one
of your for you oh yeah yeah check it
out okay
you go great i'm really excited about
the book having a book that like i'm in
is very cool and it's very exciting just
being able to see that like books in the
stories that like i can just walk to and
get it's just so fun thank you for
helping me with all the
projects and things that we do together
and adventures that we do
for breaks and school i love you thank
you
love you thank you huge smile on your
face i even
saw you breathe a little bit heavier
what was it like to see your son right
there you know it doesn't get any better
than that you know this is these are the
moments that we live for i the first
time i really felt like i need to write
this story was when we were stuck in
traffic and i got so frustrated that my
son felt that from me and he said daddy
don't get frustrated big problem or a
little problem what did you think when
he said that i thought the first thing i
thought was
wow he's really getting it yeah you know
and boy the the lessons that we teach
and what we model
but also i think you know there's a
story here because that's really the
essence of a story is it relatable
uh is it something that people can find
helpful and on a good day is it
inspiring does it move people and that's
what he did to me is he moved me to
think you know i really can slow down my
own day have a little perspective i
think as parents we need that reminder
well you clearly you know father's day
is fast approaching you clearly like
being a father why i love being a dad i
mean it's the most important job but
it's the best job because every day
you're seeing somebody experience life
for the first time and to that point you
can really feel the impact you're having
i mean he he shows it back to me all the
time we just got back from memorial day
trip and i couldn't find my keys all
right you would think after all the
driving it had my keys handy right how
many times have i opened the door to my
own place yeah i couldn't find him he's
like breathe in and out big problem a
little problem this was two days ago
right this book we've been living this
story for years i said sam do you want
to read the book again he's like daddy i
live this life
there's gonna be a time it's an
autobiography there's gonna be a time
then when he says big problem little
probably goes that's a big problem
you know but but we gotta convert them
and and just think about that the guests
that you've had on this morning and the
topics you've covered this is i want it
to be timeless yeah for moms and dads
but i also think it's timely because of
the anxiousness
it is and it's very well done this is a
big week for you new book and you have a
new job starting on monday i do i
started a new job so is that a big
problem or a little problem
happy back we'll talk about what's your
new job what's your new job i'm working
on as landscaping partners it's a
language strategy firm where we help
people solve their problems through the
power story all right thank you lucky to
have you that's been fun
so much big problems little problems on
sale now